you know it's it's all kind of it's a
double-edged sword with one side being
incredibly great and the other side
being a little you know being known for
a character in particular uh is nothing
I ever dreamed about you know my idea of
what I wanted to do was as many things
as possible and you have to think though
it's so rare for someone to embrace a
character universally right that you
think how is that gonna happen different
roles and they'll like it and I'll be
able to though it's like this boom yeah
everybody knows you you are that you are
awesome we love you and it's great and
it's awesome but it's like you're uh
you're a thespian you've always done
theater you've always wanted to do
theater you've always wanted to explore
and do all these things so I get that